today 8 news now asking Governor Joe
Lombardo for his input on the school
shooting the governor was in town for a
separate event and this was his response
it has to become a certain point zero
tolerance because of the systems you
have in place are not working and that's
no fault of anybody that developed the
law in years past you know sometimes you
have to have the data before you can
make informed decisions which leads us
to the question whether crime in the
Northeast area is up CCSD superintendent
Dr Jesus Jara believes that played a
role a key role in today's school
shooting 8 news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough spoke to those who live in the
neighborhood near Von turbo middle
school and she joins us live from Metro
headquarters with the latest
yeah it was mixed reaction for those
that live in the neighborhood as that
area has seen its fair share of crime
but should that be to blame for the
shooting that happened at Von tobel
Middle School take a listen
as soon as I hit the school Pecos and
Curry then I start seeing a lot of cops
a lot of cops with the guns you know
like facing the the streets and stuff
like that Zeta Robles and her son Juan
live right around the corner from Von
tobel Middle School where shooting
happened Monday afternoon that's why I
really got scared and I started you know
contacting my son to see how he was
doing fortunately Juan wasn't harmed and
though the suspect hasn't been Tracked
Down Zeta blames the neighborhood for
what happened
and superintendent Jesus Jara would
agree issuing this statement quote
Community issues are creeping into our
campuses affecting our students
negatively we don't feel that safe you
know because it is kind of like
dangerous in that area but according to
Metro's Northeast area command crime
stats crime is down with Society crimes
down by almost 22 percent the Clark
County Education Association says
violence in our schools is the root of
the problem and urges those in power to
take action stating quote the lack of
safety in our schools is not nothing
short of a crisis with hundreds of
deadly weapons confiscated already on
CCSD campuses this school year we
believe the situation was a school
shooting waiting to happen Jose Guzman
who heard the gunshots from his house
feels like school shootings have now
become a part of life and agrees that
the education system needs to be better
equipped to handle it security is most
important at a school you know there's
children's there and it's unfortunate
that the security wasn't there to
respond quicker
and the victim was a campus security
monitor he is currently recovering at a
nearby hospital reporting live at Metro
headquarters Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now